depuis 20 ans 50% des populations de
chauves-souris ont disparu en france
dans les yvelines le département a
décidé de lutter contre cette
disparition en 2019 une étude est lancée
dans la forêt de roncq à bullion pour
connaître les espèces l'idée c'était
déjà d'avoir une connaissance de ce
qu'on a sur le site parce que connaître
c'est le premier pas pour pour engager
des mesures pour préserver et puis
également s'était proposé des mesures de
gestion qui pourrait être mise en place
et travaux râble aux espèces qu'on
trouve sur le site et même plus
largement pour les chauves-souris en
général conclusion il existe neuf
espèces différentes dans cette forêt
mais plus qu'une simple étude sur les
chauves-souris ce rapport permet de
déterminer si l'espace est de manière
générale favorables à la biodiversité
les chauves-souris ce sont deux en fait
de bons indicateurs de l'état de santé
notamment en milieu forestier ce sont
des espèces qui sont insectivores et
déjà si on a une bonne ressource
alimentaire si on a une belle variété on
va dire dans les habitats dans les
essences et dans les laits on va dire
tout ce qui est loges pour s'abriter et
bien de savoir quelles espèces on a et
notamment un petit peu savoir qu'est ce
qu'ils font du site ça va nous permettre
de savoir si le site et on va dire
favorables à la biodiversité de manière
générale pour éviter la disparition des
chauves-souris dû au manque d'insectes à
la destruction des habitats et au
réchauffement climatique entre autres le
département créé des espaces où les
chauves souris vont pouvoir chasser mais
aussi où elles vont pouvoir se reposer
et hiberner donc là on se retrouve juste
devant un aménagement qui a été fait à
quelques années en faveur des chauves
souris
une partie haute pour garder la chaleur
pour les petits l'été une partie basse
humide pour la période d'hibernation en
hiver cet aménagement est idéal pour les
chiroptères de leur vrai nom c'est des
sites qui vont être
bien qu'ils vont venir compléter
l'existant
et aussi donc il ya pas mal de sites
aujourd'hui anciens qui avant était
favorable aux chauves-souris qui
aujourd'hui dans les restaurations de
bâtiment ne laisse pas forcément la
place donc ça permet de recréer des
sites qui leur sont favorables
aujourd'hui sur le département il existe
22 espèces de chauves souris le total
est de 31 en france